I still am like I can't stand watching
myself I have a weird thing I hear that
a lot with actors like I'm my biggest
critical look are you looking at your
face no never mind I'm just looking at
like acting my acting all right so you
you're okay looking at yourself yeah
like you're like I'm pretty I'm not
worried about that is that what you're
saying
no but it's a good thing it's good to
know that's a I'm telling you ninety
percent of actors don't like watching
themselves because they're like oh God
my nose oh look at the bags under myself
what's very interesting is in acting
even if I like I feel like I've talked
to a lot of people that are very aware
of how they're they look when they're
like crying or if they're screaming when
I'm acting if I look ugly I'm like great
good I was in it that was it I could
care less if there's like tears and I'm
like no snot coming down trust the
director yes I'm like this is acting
this is what it is like you're not in
real life like worried about like snot
coming down your nose and being like